du jeu de l'échangé surtout de la
collaboration
les énigmes d'escale game en ligne sont
destinés aux entreprises un moyen de
retrouver du lien et de donner à la
visio un autre goût à mais la cohésion
dans les équipes parce qu'elles sont
obligés de collaborer ensemble et
ensuite au niveau des sceaux ce qu'ils
on va voir qui prend le lead qui est à
l' écoute qui tendent à la parole
donc c'est pour ça que ça marche aussi
en termes de team building pour les
entreprises les écrans vont être très
similaire aux différents à vous de
devoir quand vous allez jouer mais
effectivement tout le monde à prendre la
parole et vous ne pourrez jamais réussir
les skates game tout seul dans votre
camp ou même en duo jusqu'à 100
collaborateurs peuvent jouer en
simultané
l'idée germe en 2020 lors du premier
confinement pour s'amuser en famille ou
entre amis tout juste diplômé d'une
école de management
les fondateurs se lance ensuite dans
l'entrepreneuriat
quand on nous a demandé de faire un site
internet pour que ce soit plus facile de
le jouer en entreprise
on a retroussé nos manches on a regardé
un paquet de vidéos sur youtube et on a
fini par développer notre site de jeux
tout seuls comme des grands
on avait quelqu'un qui elle nous a
demandé de faire le jeu c'est pour lui
qu'on l'a développée c'était vraiment un
challenge assez assez sympathique à
relever parce que ce qui s'est passé
c'est qu'on a eu à votre première
commande le 25 novembre et qu'on avait
toujours pas de site de jeux trouver un
antidote ou sauver un homme capturé au
sahel
deux scénarios sont pour le moment
disponibles d'une durée d'une heure et
demie en comprenant les briefings le
site lui s'est lancé le 14 décembre
dernier